miss marvel baby this is my shot  here instead of miss marvel  our actors can do everything  i feel exhilarated  i think i'm doing it trying to channel  so much  energy we go from like dancing  to a fight sequence in the matter of 24  hours  that was fun  there's so much chemistry you feel that  they're really like family feels like  i've known them like my whole life well  this has been insane but i wouldn't  trade it  and we're high-fiving  it feels like there is this new  generation coming up  [Music]  is truly the heart of the show the  greatest day of my life i was having so  much fun and i wanted to cherish every  single second of being there he's just  very fundamentally lovable it is just a  testament of their talent we have  something special lightning in the  bottle is the best way to describe it